most of srinivasa ramanujan's knowledge
came from a single mathematics book
he spent all of his time thinking about
math and little else it's no wonder he
flunked out of college twice yet somehow
he found his way to the University of
Cambridge to perform groundbreaking
research on mathematical problems
ramanujan was born on December 22nd 1887
in a roadie a town south of Madras
what's now called Chennai in South India
he was considered a miracle child the
only one of his mother's first four
children to survive infancy he also
survived an outbreak of smallpox poor
health would afflict him his whole life
yet it never slowed down his passion
math equations danced in his head as if
they appeared from thin air he believed
his gifts came from the Hindu goddess
namagiri he used to go to the nearby
serangapini Temple as a boy to sketch
complex mathematical equations in chalk
on stone slabs as a teen he got his
hands on a copy of this book of math
theorems by a British mathematician
George Carr it was meant as a teaching
aide for students however many students
actually struggled to read this book
because it listed answers without
showing the steps to get there but for
ramanujan this book awakened the genius
in it Kerr's book was like a crossword
puzzle with its empty grids begging to
be filled in as Robert Canada describes
in his biography on ramanujan he had a
natural intuition for math which can be
illustrated by this problem he solved
imagine you're on a street with 50 to
500 houses you're looking for a special
house where the sum of all house numbers
to its left equals the sum to its right
can you find it this actually happened
on a street with 288 houses the special
house was number 204 with both sides
totaling twenty thousand seven hundred
six when the Indian statistician PC
mahalanobis asked ramanujan about this
problem that he read in a magazine
ramanujan thought for a moment and gave
a formula that works for any number of
houses not just between 50 and 500 on a
street with just Eight houses house six
is special because one plus two plus
three plus four plus five equals seven
plus eight romanujan said he knew the
answer was a continued fraction showing
his unique ability to see patterns that
others would miss
he received a scholarship to study at
the reputable government arts college in
his hometown of kumbakonim however his
obsession with math got in the way he
flunked his English composition paper
lost his scholarship and dropped out
because his family couldn't afford the
32 rupee tuition per term a substantial
amount of money at the time his father
worked as a clerk in asari shop and
never made more than 20 rupees a month
ramanujan felt humiliated and ran away
from home he gave University another
shot but failed the entrance exams
administered by the University of Madras
again and again he scored less than 10
percent on the physiology exam a former
student whom he tutored in math recalled
his state of mind he used to bemoan his
wretched conditions in life he would
reply that many a great man like Galileo
died in Inquisition and his lot would be
to die in poverty but I continued to
encourage him that God who is great
would surely help him his failures
turned out to be a blessing in disguise
because now he could focus on his one
true passion he educated himself with
that outdated math book and began
feverishly stuffing his notebooks with
new formulas of his own totaling nearly
4 000 in his lifetime he started to
build a reputation after publishing his
work in the first academic Journal
dedicated to mathematics in India the
Indian mathematical Society but it
wasn't long before he had to find a job
at the age of 21 ramanujan's parents
arranged his marriage to nine-year-old
janaki a distant relative such Customs
were common then he began working as an
accounting clerk at the Port of Madras a
big shipping hub known today as the port
of Chennai as luck would have it his
direct supervisor happened to be a
mathematician and the head of the port
was a British engineer they encouraged
him to write to English mathematicians
about his discoveries but two esteemed
Cambridge mathematicians rejected him
however a third was intrigued in January
1913 G.H Hardy a fellow of Trinity
College at the University of Cambridge
received a letter from ramanujan that
read dear sir I beg to introduce myself
to you as a clerk in the accounts
Department of the port trust office at
Madras on a salary of only 20 pounds per
annum I am now about 23 years of age I
have had no University education after
leaving school I have been employing the
spare time at my disposal to work at
mathematics I have made a special
investigation of Divergent series in
general and the results I get are termed
by the local mathematicians as startling
the startling claim is that adding up
all positive integers one two three four
4 and so on to Infinity added up to
negative 1 12. bear in mind this isn't
your typical addition Divergent series
emerge from a complex mathematical
process
ramanujan's letter was 10 pages long
consisting mostly of technical results
from a wide range of mathematics he
claimed to have a technique for counting
prime numbers number is greater than one
that can only be divided by one and
itself prime numbers are notoriously
hard to predict it's like trying to
understand if there's a pattern to let
you know exactly when your favorite song
will be played on the radio although
ramanujan failed to find a perfect
formula for predicting primes his work
provided fresh insights into their
distribution he also included theorems
related to integral calculus integral
calculus can be likened to slicing up a
sausage and then reassembling it by
making it whole or integral it's a
mathematical tool with real world
applications like determining the drag
on a plane's Wing as a plane flies the
air hits the wing in tiny slices over
time each contributing to drag integral
calculus adds up these small effects to
calculate the total drag ramanujan's
letter to Hardy ended this way being
poor if you are convinced that there is
anything of value I would like to have
my theorems published being
inexperienced I would very highly value
any advice you give me requesting to be
excused for the trouble I give you I
remain Dear Sir yours truly srinivasa
ramanujan
Hardy didn't know what to make this
unusual letter from a young man five
thousand miles away was this a practical
joke or had he just stumbled upon the
second Sir Isaac Newton Hardy showed the
letter to his colleague GE littlewood
who was equally amazed some of the
formulas were familiar others Hardy
remarked seemed scarcely possible to
believe he concluded that the letter was
certainly the most remarkable that I
have ever received Hardy responded to
ramanujan I was exceedingly interested
by your letter and by the theorems which
you state you will however understand
that before I can judge properly of the
value of what you have done it is
essential that I should see proofs of
some of your assertions such proof was
required if others were to be convinced
of the results however ramanujan didn't
bother explaining how he arrived at his
conclusions he just slept from insight
to Insight perhaps he took a page out of
the book that so inspired him in his
response to Hardy's request to see proof
ramanujan mentioned his Divergent series
result writing if I tell you this you
will let once point out to me the
lunatic asylum as my goal ramanujan
wanted someone of stature like Hardy to
recognize the worth in his work so that
he could get a scholarship since I am
already a half starving man two preserve
my brains I want food Hardy wanted to
arrange a scholarship for him to study
at Cambridge but crossing the ocean was
considered a serious violation of
ramanujan's devout Orthodox Hindu faith
that could lead to losing his caste
status
Hardy's colleague E.H Neville who was
lecturing in Madras had the task of
convincing ramanujan to go to Cambridge
he assured him his strict vegetarian
diet would be respected in England any
concerns ramanujan had disappeared after
his mother had a vivid dream in which
the Hindu goddess namagiri instructed
her not to hinder her son's destiny
on March 17 1914 ramanujan set sail for
the Journey of his life he prepared for
European Life by learning to eat with a
knife in fork and learning to tie a tie
after a three-day Journey he arrived at
Trinity College Cambridge to start an
extraordinary collaboration he and Hardy
couldn't have been any more different
ramanujan was a self-taught savant who
believed equations expressed the
thoughts of God Hardy was a Cambridge
professor and an avowed atheist who
refused to believe what he could not
prove yet their partnership flourished
ramanujan and Hardy contributed
substantially to number Theory a branch
of mathematics that deals with the
fascinating properties and patterns
found within ordinary numbers one of
their most notable Works calculated the
partitions of a number four can be
partitioned or broken down in five ways
while this may sound straightforward
figuring out how many ways a number can
be partitioned becomes increasingly
complex with larger numbers the number
of partitions of 50 is 204
226. this is practical implications that
aren't immediately obvious partitions
can help computers operate more
efficiently by dividing tasks or data
into smaller parts devices can process
information quicker ramanujan pressed on
with his work despite being in poor
health for much of his five years in
England the Colder Weather didn't help
he was once found shivering in his
Cambridge room sleeping atop the
blankets unaware he should be under them
maintaining a nutritious vegetarian diet
was also difficult in light of the
rationing imposed during World War One
he also skipped meals and ate at random
hours of the day with no mother or wife
to care for him ramanujan was eventually
diagnosed with tuberculosis in a severe
vitamin deficiency being ill and far
away from his family also affected his
mental well-being in 1918 he threw
himself onto the tracks of the London
Underground in front of an approaching
train luckily a guard spotted him and
pulled a switch bringing the train to a
stop a few feet before hitting him
his spirits improved considerably later
that year when Britain's Elite body of
scientists the Royal Society named him a
fellow the second Indian at the time to
be so honored he was elected partly for
his work on elliptic functions which are
used to explain complex shapes and
patterns elliptic functions can
accurately describe the movement of
planets around the sun which is neither
A Perfect Circle nor an exact oval it's
like having a super detailed map of the
movement of planets becoming a fellow of
the Royal Society is believed to have
stimulated the discovery of some of his
most beautiful theorems which she
continued to develop Upon returning to
India in 1919 to a hero's welcome
his life inspired the movie The Man Who
Knew Infinity reflecting his profound
insights into the nature of infinity an
example is pie which starts with 3.14
and has an infinite number of decimal
places we can never write down every
single digit of pi because there's no
end to them ramanujan got us closer and
closer to this mysterious number in a
faster way
back home in India ramanujan kept in
touch with Professor Hardy and in a
letter that turned out to be his last he
hinted at an incredible Discovery dear
Hardy I am extremely sorry for not
writing you a single letter up to now I
discovered very interesting functions
recently which I call mock Theta
functions mock Theta functions are a
highly abstract concept like a secret
math code mathematicians are still
trying to understand in 2012
mathematician Ken Ono rolad and
ramanujan's mock Theta functions to
devise a new math formula to better
understand black holes this approach
helps calculate the entropy of black
holes a measure of how much information
gets scrambled or mixed up inside
ramanujan's cryptic work still conceals
many mathematical Treasures waiting to
be discovered as Ono put it it's like he
was writing down a Bible for us but it
was incomplete he gave us glimpses of
what the future would be and our job is
to figure it out ramanujan Left Behind
three notebooks packed with his formulas
and loose pages that were only
discovered in 1976. he was still
scribbling away four days before he died
on April 26 1920. ramanujan was only 32
years old
most of his Orthodox relatives stayed
away from his funeral because they
considered him tainted for having
crossed the waters to England and he had
been too ill to make it to the
purification ceremonies his mother had
arranged at the seaside
when Hardy was invited to receive an
honorary degree at Harvard he mentioned
in his speech that the most significant
achievement of his life was discovering
ramanujan I did not invent him like
other great men he invented himself but
I was the first really competent person
who had the chance to see some of his
work and I can still remember with
satisfaction that I could recognize at
once what a treasure I had found my
association with him is the one romantic
incident in my life foreign
we are left to wonder how many
ramanujans are in India today or
elsewhere waiting to be discovered this
isn't just a story about a brilliant
mathematician it's a story about how
educational institutions can nurture
talent and hinder it sometimes the
traditional classroom isn't the best
place for learning math that's why I
trust brilliant a website and app where
you can learn math data science and
computer science interactively
Brilliance mathematical thinking course
will change the way you see numbers as
you tackle real world problems involving
fractions percentages and ratios no
matter where you're at in your Learning
Journey brilliant customizes content to
fit your needs and you can solve at your
own pace there are no tests I like to
take a few minutes out of my day to
sharpen my analytical thinking skills
with their logic puzzles
so why not try out brilliant for free
for 30 days by heading to the custom
link in my description
brilliant.org newsthink in the first 200
people who sign up through my custom
link will receive a 20 discount on
Brilliance premium annual subscription
unlocking all of the courses
thanks for watching I'm Cindy Palm